>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C..
>>Larry Applebaum: My
name is Larry Applebaum
from the Music Division here
at the Library of Congress.
It's always fun to
talk to John Szwed.
You know we were talking
earlier today when you arrived,
and we started to
get into some things.
And one thing led to another.
And I looked at my watch,
and three hours had flown by.
And that's what it's like
to talk to John Szwed.
He brings-- and it's not just
because he's an anthropologist.
It's not just because he's
an author and a biographer.
And a scholar.
It's that he has this
abiding curiosity
about all things
certainly related to music.
But even beyond music.
John, welcome back to
the Library of Congress.
>> John Szwed: Thanks,
thanks very much.
>> Larry Applebaum: It's
not your first time here.
Do you remember your first
time here at the Library?
>> John Szwed: To doing
something for the Library?
Or just wandering in?
>> Larry Applebaum: Well, I
mean to do some work here.
>> John Szwed: It was
Jelly Roll Morton.
Yes, the Jelly Roll
Morton boxed set.
And we did the staff dug up the
original mics, and it was kind
of interesting to see what
people actually used to talk
to when, record with in 193--
what was the date of it?
Thirty-eight, thirty-nine,
forty?
Somewhere in there?
Yeah.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Thirty-eight, yeah.
You won a Grammy for that.
For the booklet for that.
>> John Szwed: I did.
I suppose I should have
shared it with the Library.
>> Larry Applebaum: Well it's an
important piece of scholarship.
It's an interesting story also.
Why don't we talk, talk
just a little bit about that
because it was one of the great
pleasures for me as an engineer
as I got to work with the
original discs to transfer them.
We literally got them into
the right speed, finally.
Which meant the songs
are in the right key.
But what did you actually do?
What were you-- what
materials did you work
with to inform your public?
>> John Szwed: Well, the
real challenge and I,
I don't need [inaudible]
if they're,
they're challenges is that.
I remember a teacher saying to
me once, "What would you say
about a person who made claims
that were absolutely
unbelievable,
like 'I invented this or that?
You know, I was the first
to do this and that.'
And you know this is wrong.
Do you just blow him off
as a blowhard and a fool?
But then you find out
he was 90% accurate
but everyone won't
acknowledge that?"
And I thought, "Now,
that's fascinating."
So the guy has been treated
as a buffoon in some ways.
And in his time as a nuisance.
But he was telling the truth
with the things he claimed.
So that was my first test
to see just how much
this person could do.
And the joke was on me.
You know, I may have
gotten a Grammy for it.
But months later, I found
out more and more and more
and thought, "Oh
boy, I missed this."
I mean, could a guy claim
that he invented jazz?
And could claim that he been
a hit at all sorts of media?
That he sold thousands
of records, et cetera?
And also been a boxing promoter?
And also formed the first
multi-racial film company
and D-- it was in
D.C. by the way.
And also been in auto racing
with Jack Johnson, the boxer?
And it goes on and
on and had a wife
who ran an award-winning
restaurant?
I had missed all that.
>> Larry Applebaum: How
did you learn these facts?
>> John Szwed: From a British
website which obsessively seemed
to track down everything
you could find in the world.
There are such sites
where people seem to
live in that site.
And they live for that moment.
It makes you wonder then is it
possible to do all those things?
I suppose.
I mean, no one's
claimed otherwise.
And to use the name of--
Jack Johnson turned out
to have been a musician
as well as a boxer.
Had a band, recorded, and
used to take a gigantic,
oversized bass around with
him to play with things.
So you know this is
perfectly reasonable.
Oh! I left out something.
While he was doing the show
at the Library of Congress.
It wasn't a show, it
was a recording session.
He had a radio show in Baltimore
making him the first radio DJ
of that kind of music.
It was presumably promoting his
own music as well as others.
But there you have it.
Well, [inaudible].
>> Larry Applebaum: Are there
any surviving [inaudible]?
>> John Szwed: Not
that I could find.
This would be '30-- , '38
something like that, '39.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Any description
of what the contents-- ?
>> John Szwed: It was
called The History of Jazz.
But it could have been anything.
>> Larry Applebaum:
So did he invent jazz?
>> John Szwed: He's
the first person
to copyright a composition
which is called Jazz.
He certainly broke with
the previous tradition.
I don't know.
I mean, there's an
Italian film about this.
What's it called?
The Legend of 19-- something?
It's a very, very popular
cult film in Italy.
I can't think, Sixteen, maybe?
And let's see, Clarence--
I forget who plays.
It's about, it's about a
pianist-- it's a long story.
But it has to do with
a person who claims
to have superhuman
abilities at a keyboard
because he spent his whole
life on a boat with a keyboard.
It's challenged by
Jelly Roll Morton.
He's challenged by
Jelly Roll Morton
who claims he's the
greatest pianist alive.
And Morton clearly beats him.
But by the magic of film, the
other guy grows two extra arms.
And plays basically
four-handed piano and beats him.
But-- . The end of the year--
you know, he wrote a
film that's really awful.
I don't know who ever said this,
but really awful films
sometimes have one line
that make it worth
sitting through.
And the one line in this film,
I can't say for under our
current circumstances.
But two longshoremen years later
were walking by, and they said,
"And what did Morton
say after he got beat?
He said, 'Jazz.'" So
[laughter] it was worth sitting
through the film to watch
them destroy the film
in a way with that one line.
>> Larry Applebaum: So let
me get some context for you
and your curiosity
and what draws you
to these kind of stories.
Now what came first?
Your interest as a trombonist or
your interest in anthropology?
>> John Szwed: Well, I was,
I was a musician
very early in life.
I was, I was a union member,
14, something like that.
I had, I played bass.
>> Larry Applebaum:
This was where?
>> John Szwed: Where?
In, in South Jersey.
Outside Philadelphia.
I played bass, a couple
of other instruments.
And that seemed a
reasonable thing to do
for a long while,
right into school.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Were you any good?
>> John Szwed: I was a union
member, does that count?
I don't know.
[Laughter]
>> Larry Applebaum: That
just means you pay your dues.
>> John Szwed: Well,
I got hired.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay, good.
Professional.
>> John Szwed: I, I,
I played, you know,
I played symphony gigs.
I played R&B stuff.
You know, rock, I
mean, whatever.
And it was a way of living.
It was a way of learning.
I found it fascinating I
found, you know, great people.
It wasn't an easy life.
And I sort of drifted
into college.
I drifted into anthropology.
Why I stuck with it was I had
a teacher who was Austrian
and she spent a lot of
time talking about the US
as if it were a foreign country.
Which it was for her.
And every time she
would do this,
it would put me in
a different place.
I'd be looking at something
or other and say, "Wow,
it's not what I,
quite what I thought."
And we were keeping
scrapbooks of things
that struck us that way.
And I realized that it was a way
that you could put
yourself at a distance.
Still be a member and know what
you are, the society you are in.
And still see it
in a different way.
And that, that really
fascinated me.
I thought most people don't
have any impulse to do that.
I don't mean that
you become a critic.
You just step back and say,
"What's this scene about?
What are these people doing?
Why are they, why are they
so enthusiastic about it?
And why do they think
it's so unique?"
[Clears throat] That
it's, that it's so special
when so many other
people do the same thing?
And one of the things I
remember being stunned by,
right in my first
class was there was--
I forget the exact number.
There, there are
36 or seven kinds
of kinship systems in the world.
That's it.
And they repeat.
They occur in different
places that are not connected.
As if someone rolled dice
and kept rolling them.
And they're coming up this way.
Then I found that languages
weren't infinitely possible.
They were limitations
all over the place.
And I was fascinated
with the idea that people
who think they're the only
ones who do something,
or the only ones
who have something.
There's so many other
people doing the same thing,
thinking the same way.
And I, I thought, as I
became a journalist later on.
That this should
be a thing in the--
what they used to call a manual
or guide for the journalists.
What not to do.
You should never say, "This
is the only, that's the first,
that's the last, or
this is the death of."
Something the Washington Post,
I must say, is very easy doing.
They're always killing things.
The death of the novel.
The death of the film.
I always quote [inaudible]
one of the people I wrote
about who said, "A
music doesn't die.
You can find music
in any major city
of the world whether it's
18th century, you know,
Philippines, whatever.
At some night of the
week, they're going
to be playing that stuff."
You know, musics don't die.
They can't die.
It's musicians die.
He says, "They've been dying
for the last 20 years."
And I, then I was thinking,
well you know, that's true.
The talk about it that dies.
It's not the, the subject.
It goes on.
This is around the world or
well you asked the question.
But I found that was, it wasn't
so much a subject
to make a living at.
But it was a way of living.
And then, yeah, I guess you
could say musicians have the
same kind of position.
They stare at audiences
and wonder just what is
the show about exactly?
>> Larry Applebaum: You,
you alluded to something.
This ability to have
a critical detachment
that enables you to observe.
>> John Szwed: With
suspension of criticism.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay,
so is that something you had
to train yourself to do?
Or were you able to
do this instinctively?
>> John Szwed: No, I
won't say, not at all.
I mean, it was, having
been born in the South
in pre-Civil Rights days.
Then brought to a northern
deeply-- what do we say today?
Diverse community,
that was a jolt.
>> Larry Applebaum:
The awareness [inaudible]
by the way.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, and,
and black, black belt,
red clay country, it was
Green County, Alabama.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay.
>> John Szwed: But my first
gigs were with all black bands,
so I passed the first
test, I guess.
That was kind of a jolt.
I think, I think one thing was
I took a linguistics course.
And one of the first
exercises was to try to figure
out that why you shouldn't write
when you're writing
phonetically the word.
I'm trying to think.
Whale. W-h-a-l-e, and w-a-i-l.
There's a slight
difference in pronunciation,
but you can't hear it.
I mean, it's there
if [inaudible].
Oh, a better example.
If you, I forget
the rule for this.
But if you say "spin" you hear a
little [inaudible] the s, right?
If you say "pin,"
you don't hear any.
If you put a match, lit match in
front of your face or a candle
and say "spin" the
candle doesn't go out.
You say "pin" it goes out.
There's a tiny gust of
air that comes with it.
You don't hear it,
but it's there.
So it's fascinating
with the idea
that there were things
right in our language,
right in our mouths that we
don't know what they are.
And only a person who's standing
way back from it and looks at it
and says, "Yes, that's
not the same.
W-h-a-l-e- and w-a-i-l
are not the same sounds.
You just think they are.
>> Larry Applebaum: I
don't hear any real accent,
but when you go back to
Alabama, does it come back?
>> John Szwed: I don't
go back to Alabama.
It's a-- [Laughter].
Do you remember Dizzy
Gillespie's line?
>> Larry Applebaum: I'll
never go back to Georgia.
>> John Szwed: Remember
when he said he would repeat
that in the [inaudible]
and then say, "Would you?"
Oh, I did go back for
this [inaudible] thing.
And -- it was better
than I remember it.
I went to, I went to
a Lebanese restaurant
where they were playing salsa.
And I thought, this has got
to be better than I thought.
And then I went to my
hometown which was really--
i mean, it's nothing changed.
It's Faulkner country.
It's forest primeval.
It's everything's just the same.
And it turned out that two of
the wildest musicians going are
from that little town.
It's Larry Applebaum:
Donna Smith and Davy-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: Williams.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, they're
both in that little town.
>> Larry Applebaum: Really?
>> John Szwed: And
I said to them,
"So how'd you break
loose from this town?
I got moved by my parents."
They said they went to
Tuscaloosa once to a drug store.
And the drug store
was selling records.
And these records are all black
and white colored, and they,
they look very strange.
The pictures were strange.
And across the top it
said, "You never heard
such sounds in your life."
I said, "Well, they
were ESP records?"
So yes, we thought they were
extra sensory perception,
but it was really Esperanzo.
>> Larry Applebaum: Esperanto.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, so they
had walked into, they had walked
into the most avante of
the music at the time
from their little town.
They went back saying, "We
really haven't heard anything
like this in our life."
>> Larry Applebaum: Do
you think people change
with their environment?
And I, I guess-- .
>> John Szwed: In what sense?
>> Larry Applebaum:
The reason I ask.
Did it really change
you and, and if so how?
When you moved from
Alabama to New Jersey?
>> John Szwed: Well, I mean.
I think we first lived in a sort
of flea bag hotel
when I first moved.
My family in one
room for a long time.
And my mother used to
give me money to go
across the street
to the theater.
It was a movie theater.
And it wasn't segregated
theater, at least nor formally.
But on Tuesdays,
they had black films.
So I was watching black films
thinking they were Hollywood
films, so I saw things like one
that's actually getting some
currency now.
I've forgotten for what reason.
Called Sepia Cinderella.
And another one called
Two-Gun Slinger from Harlem.
And I mean, you know, I took,
I took this to be Hollywood.
I thought this was what it was.
But it was not, it was
not something I'd seen
in the South for sure.
And they wouldn't even have
been showing those films,
I don't think.
At least certain neighborhoods.
And they always had musical
things that went with it.
And I was really taken by
the, [inaudible] basically.
They were the kind of things
they played is video jukeboxes
in those days.
Most people didn't
realize videos went back
that far, but they do.
And these musicians
were pretty amazing.
So I drifted somehow or other
to seeing Lionel Hampton's band.
When I was still
a kid on my own.
And a huge theater.
It must have been the,
not the Earle, yeah,
the Earle Theater
in Philadelphia.
All black audience.
And I was blown away.
It was, it was the, it was a
different performance aesthetic.
It was-- see if I
can be more specific.
Well, when, when soloists
would walk to the microphone,
they walked with a kind of
confidence and, and assuredness
that I'd never seen before
with people of color.
And I'd never seen it with
white people for that matter.
These were people
who were completely
at home with their idiom.
This is their idiom.
This is their thing.
I was really, I was
really affected by that.
I found other people who had
that same kind of reaction.
They, they thought this was
a different way of being.
You didn't have to
have a lot of money.
You only had to have
a skill, a high skill
that nobody else
shared with you.
And I thought the
humor of the crowd
and so forth was
quite different.
I, I was thinking, "I've
been missing something."
And then when I first played
in, in African American bands,
and for African American
audiences.
You know, I was, I
drifted into that.
I was comfortable in it.
There was some-- I was
not surprised by it.
I was-- it was the way of
life that I could deal with.
And again, it's coming
in from the outside.
Coming up north from the south.
Coming in from white to black.
I don't make any claims
on ever being black.
I'm just making claims
on appreciating things
that I didn't know about before.
And coming to see that they
were within our civilization,
whole varieties of
being human that were,
that were very powerful.
And they were, engines of
creativity, if you want.
They were generating
one thing after another.
And, and as I got older
and saw that they,
this was the way show business
works, that you're kind
of continually-- show
business and, and,
and all the arts, I guess.
The fashion, the rest of it.
You have to continually
reject what you had
to introduce a new
audience and sell it again.
But in the process,
it ends up recycling.
So that when, when people my age
would say to their grandchildren
or something or other, "Why,
I remember when back
in my day-- ."
It's true!
Those shoes on those
'40s actresses?
Whoa. [Inaudible]
He's charging what?
I don't know.
A thousand dollars a pair?
Barbara Stanwyck
was wearing them
in 1942 in Double Indemnity.
This is not a surprise, right?
>> Larry Applebaum:
Right, indeed.
>> John Szwed: And rap, may
I say quickly, was introduced
by Louis Armstrong,
right, 1920-- four, five?
Where he's talking
rhythmically over a song?
>> Larry Applebaum:
At least on record.
>> John Szwed: And, I must say.
In a much hipper, he's
putting a three beat
over a four in his rap.
And there's only a few rappers
who can pull that off today.
>> Larry Applebaum: Good point.
>> John Szwed: And if I
find rap is a little corny,
it's because their rhythms
are, shall we say, old?
>> Larry Applebaum: As
a musician in your case,
you had to assimilate African
American aesthetic in order
to be able to play
with these bands.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, but radio
was already a self-assimilator.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay.
>> John Szwed: I mean, the
radio waves were filled with,
when we moved to Birmingham,
with the thing I most remember
is the gospel quartets had a
distinctive style.
When the soloists were going,
there was a riff behind it
that was often something like
the words "Chanka-lanka."
Chanka-lanka, chanka-lanka,
and so on.
>> Larry Applebaum: Is
that like a jubilee style?
>> John Szwed: Yeah, yeah.
And it was, they were
writing on top of it.
And I didn't at the time know
that there were dance bands
that did this, you know.
R&B bands were going to do it.
And that that was
a certain style.
There was an audience
style even.
It was a way of supporting
everything.
So I heard that stuff,
and it wasn't--
i think I heard it more
than country music.
I do faintly remember
Hank Williams,
even Hank Williams was
halfway there, right?
He'd, he'd come up with
a black guitar player.
He was always on the
edge of the Blues.
Or, or something.
>> Larry Applebaum: I kind of
listen to the way he phrases.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, and
look, I mean taking--
he was doing what,
mock Cajun accents.
And he had the whole thing
from teenage songs, car songs,
really sad songs
about death and dying.
And lonely people.
He covered the whole,
whole realm.
And country music has always
had that reach, I guess.
When it's the question of
going white to black, I,
this is [inaudible]
territory always.
It's always, in any age
you bring these topics up,
they take a different,
a different angle.
I mean-- .
Unless you're living in
a dream world, you don't,
don't know that, that certain
per, performance patterns,
speech styles, taste,
sports, gestures,
et cetera are all shared widely.
It shouldn't be a
surprise to you
when these things
turn up crisscrossing.
I know people who talk
about you know co-optation
and you know stealing
each other's culture.
But we're in a culture
which lives on cooptation.
Lives on stealing other,
other people's culture.
I once gave a talk when
I was pretty young.
Someone said, "What's
it like-- ?"
In the audience, said,
"What's it like to be living
on somebody else's culture?"
I said, "Is there anyone in
the room here who's not living
on somebody else's culture?"
Come on. I mean, that doesn't
give you the license to,
well I guess you don't a
license to copy people.
It's done all the time.
But-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: How
about appropriation?
>> John Szwed: Yeah,
but there's, I mean,
that's the nature of art.
I mean, art lives on that.
I don't know that much about
painting, but more I learn
about it, the more I realize
that one thing is
spinning off another.
And the painters are
much closer to each other
than I thought in their styles.
And the, [inaudible]
we're talking classes.
I, I, I always come
back to that cliche.
I think it's from Stravinsky
when he said something like,
"Hack musicians, hack
composers borrow.
Serious composers steal."
[Laughter]
>> Larry Applebaum:
As an anthropologist,
did you specialize in
an area of the world?
>> John Szwed: Well,
I thought I did.
I was set to go to the Caribbean
and couldn't find any
way to pay for it.
And getting kind of desperate.
I saw an ad for Canadian
government was, wanted people
to do studies of agricultural
regions in northeastern Canada.
So I thought well,
Plan B, you know?
That could be alright,
I don't know.
I think I read Henderson,
The Rain King,
where Henderson's anthropologist
sort of he's been to Africa,
and he winds up in Newfoundland.
Or Labrador, I guess.
I thought, [inaudible].
So, so instead of the
Caribbean, I was headed off
for 27-foot snowdrifts.
And what have you.
And so that's what
I did for a while.
And then I thought I deserved
to, to go back to the Caribbean.
I did some time in
South Carolina.
And then I went to Trinidad
and Jamaica for a while.
And got into that.
But I think overall,
I wanted to do music.
And it, it sounds like you
should be able to do it
because it, you know, it's part
of human life and what have you.
But I ran into trouble
everywhere I went.
The first place I was
at Temple University
where there were no courses
on African American anything.
Despite being in an
African American community
in Philadelphia.
So I, I thought I
could give a course
in African American music.
And be the first.
So I offered to do it for free.
Which is the same.
Not because I needed money
but because nobody does
anything free in universities.
So I hear back from the Dean of
the [inaudible] saying I went
around him to contact another
dean, and that wasn't allowed.
And the other said no, they
weren't going to do that.
Well, that was a beginning.
Some years later, I
was at Yale University.
A much-esteemed and
celebrated place.
And I thought since I was
writing a book on Miles Davis,
I might off a seminar
on Miles Davis.
So I said I would do that.
It was rejected.
Number one, because Yale
doesn't normally do seminars
on individual people.
And number two, because
Miles Davis hadn't
accomplished enough.
Well, I, I was thinking of
responding in some vile,
nasty way when the
person who's in charge
of such things in my department.
Noted there were 37 such
seminars going that semester.
Including on Gershwin
and others.
But there'd never been any,
anyone doing an African
American before.
So when I pointed it
out, I got apologized to,
but nonetheless,
it was the same.
Oh, I actually skipped a year.
The first job I ever
had was in Cincinnati
where they had never had
anything on African Americans.
And I said I would offer
some kind of course.
And the chair of the department
said it's a non-subject.
It's a non-subject, he said.
And I read him to be saying
on a non-people taught
by a non-professor.
I don't know.
So I'd had three, three--
by the way, the Miles
Davis thing was in 2006.
So it's not ancient history.
But then I remember that one of
the colleagues I had at Yale,
still alive, was the first
Jew hired at Penn State.
So it's not, we're not
talking ancient history here.
>> Larry Applebaum: I
want to ask you more
about the Miles Davis.
And, and your other
books, the Sun Ra,
the Billie Holiday,
the Alan Lomax.
But you've used this
term already.
For African American music.
And I ask this question,
it's a naive question,
but I ask it anyway.
I asked this of Ingrid
Monsan when she was here.
What do you think is African
about African American music?
>> John Szwed: You could have
said what's American about it.
>> Larry Applebaum:
We could do that next.
>> John Szwed: It's African.
That's only partly glib.
Well, there are several
ways to think of it.
You could think of it
very musicologically
and say do we actually find
swing rhythm in Africa?
I think we do.
And I think it's, you
could point to some places.
They're not always where
you'd expect to find them.
But they're nonetheless there.
And when someone would say well,
so-and-so region doesn't
sound anything like that.
Well, that's true.
Africa's a very complex place.
So put it in that big a,
to put it in that big a
category is a problem.
But then we don't have any
trouble saying European,
and Europe's full of
diversity from top to bottom.
And from north to south Europe,
performance styles are
radically different.
And so I, I don't
feel bad about that.
Are we saying that
there's something
in African American music you're
not going to find anywhere else?
Yes. I'll start with
the obvious one.
I mean, I, I say this, and
I'm violating my own rules.
You don't say anything
is the first or the only.
But you know show
me if I'm wrong.
Simultaneous improvised
collective music is not found
anywhere else.
At least not at my knowledge.
That is the musicians come in
with only the smallest of what?
Smallest framework to
work with, maybe harmonic,
maybe rhythmic, whatever.
And they proceed to collectively
with separate lines,
without rehearsal,
without planning
to make these lines
weave together.
And the wonderful
part of at least
in its earliest years
is they never clash.
You can't find let's say
an early New Orleans record
where there was, some
musician's really playing wrong.
So somehow they've
got this all flowing.
I think this is one huge,
enormous kind of distinction.
But there are others.
The idea of multiple rhythms,
putting rhythms on
top of each other.
Not that it doesn't
happen in Europe.
It just doesn't happen much.
Three over four.
Things that drummers in
Europe didn't know how
to do until very recently.
And the amazing part was it took
one drummer playing a drum set,
an American invention.
To do this.
Now in Africa, you have multiple
drummers playing at once.
But not the same
drumming pattern.
In Europe, in America
and England,
you had them playing
the same pattern.
So it had this distinction.
The, the remarkable thing is
that one drummer could
incorporate all the rhythms
of three or four drummers in
one set using feet and hands
in four distinctive ways.
I remember saying something
to a class once about that
and saying the, in Africa where
you have these multiple drums.
They often are, the rhythms are
associated with certain deities.
And they may be named even,
even baptized with names,
and rubbed with oils
and so forth.
And the student raised
their hand and said,
"So if one drummer is
playing all the drums,
it's like polytheism, right?"
[Laughter] I said,
"If, if you will.
Why not?" But I had
thought that the drum--
if you look at a drum
kit, even the modern one.
The drums aren't all
from the same place.
The cymbals are still
primarily a Turkish phenomenon.
You know? Zildjian is
still the state of the art.
Stamped with, oftentimes
with Arabic letters, is it?
Tom-toms came in from not
from Native Americans.
But from China and the
early ones look like that.
The, the, they were, used
to be little bell-like
things made of wood.
Now they're, you don't
see them too often,
the wood blocks were
originally called temple blocks.
They were coming in from
Buddhists and others.
It's like you're seeing the
collapse of empire in this set.
You know, someone just said,
"I want all that stuff.
Bring it in."
And then you watch very
rapidly how it changes.
The cymbals are first
of all hanging.
And the drummers only play on
one thing at a time at first.
Then they'll switch
to the drums.
And then somebody
figures out a way
that they can make the
cymbals die faster.
Or bring it down into reach.
And then they put two together
so they're clapped shut.
And then you put a pedal on it.
And then up to, I don't know,
into the teens and twenties,
drummers were still
kicking the bass drum.
They still called
it a kick drum.
>> Larry Applebaum: No pedal?
>> John Szwed: Yeah, and even,
even when they put the pedal in,
some drummers were still
kicking it for effect
because it was a
different kind of thing.
That plus, if I can
get really weird here.
The brushes.
We're still talking these,
no the brushes are
certainly not European.
They look to me.
Well, let me put it this way.
The first brushes weren't
brushes for [inaudible].
They were fly swatters.
They were portable fly swatters.
Now we're getting into--
with that we're getting
into African--
what are those things called?
You see them-- Eddie
Murphy used to use them,
pretending to be an African,
swirling this thing around.
Fly swat-- you know
[inaudible] kind of fly swatter.
Am I getting arcane
enough with this?
>> Larry Applebaum: Maybe.
>> John Szwed: It's also the
way the instruments are played.
And bending notes.
I mean, I don't mean
just Blues influence.
I mean, making the instrument
do what it's not supposed to do.
Which is now I know an
Avant Garde technique.
But it, you'll know
this very well.
But the 1964 Carnegie Hall
concert with Miles Davis.
He plays My Funny Valentine.
And he opens by fingering
the horn correctly
but with no vibrato.
There's no quiver to is.
And rather awkwardly.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Like an amateur.
Da, da, da, da.
And to an audience that's just
paid big bucks to see this.
This must be kind of strange
to see a great trumpet
player sounding
like he didn't know how
to play the trumpet.
But then the next part is
supposed to go up, the tune.
Da, da, da, da.
He goes down, da, da, da.
He goes down so low
that it sounds
like his other instrument.
Then he comes soaring back up,
way over where the
other part was.
And then stops, then
stops playing
for about one bar and a half.
That'd be about five seconds..
And the feeling in the
audience was he's lost.
He comes back in on a note
played on the third valve
which can't be played
on the third valve.
That is he's forcing
it with his lip.
He could have played it on
the right valve, but instead,
he's playing it on the
wrong one and it's wavering.
[Makes trumpet sound].
Now, that's a tour de force of
saying I'm not going to play
like this instrument's
meant to be played.
I'm going to have
my audience hang
on the idea is this
guy a complete fraud?
Is he losing it?
>> Larry Applebaum: There are
different kinds of virtuosity.
It's not all about velocity.
>> John Szwed: Yes, and then in
Miles' case, he would say some--
sometimes you should play less.
Well, you know the secret.
Herbie Hancock said, "When I
asked Miles what I should be
playing,"-- that
was, how's he put it?
I don't know what
I'm supposed to play.
And he said, "Then don't play."
And then at one point
he said, Miles said,
"Try sitting on your
right hand."
So he's left with
nothing but the chords.
Then Miles said, "Now sit
on the other hand, too."
[Laughter]
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah!
>> John Szwed: So
it's, it becomes.
And then Count Basie used to
say, it's not what he plays,
it's what he doesn't play.
Which they also said of
Paul McCartney playing bass.
But you know.
>> Larry Applebaum:
That's also a variation
on play what you don't know.
>> John Szwed: Which
is what Miles said
to John McLaughlin, right?
He said, "Play the guitar like
you'd never played it before."
>> Larry Applebaum: So Miles has
come up several times already
in our conversation and we
were talking about him earlier.
It's unavoidable.
So you wrote a book about Miles.
And you know I mean we
all know that jazz fans
in particular hold very
close to their methodologies.
There's ideas that people have
about these figures they love.
Or the music that they love.
How beholden are
you to these myths?
Are you seeking to unravel them?
Or what is your intent when
you're trying to do research?
How can you tell a story
that hasn't been told
100 times already?
>> John Szwed: Well, the only,
the only books I ever wrote were
on things that I thought people
would never write on them.
And they were fascinating to me.
That was the case with Sun Ra.
Or the stories about
them was so wrong.
Like Jelly Roll Morton.
Who was, who was
an intellectual.
I mean he was an
extremely shrewd guy.
Or Miles which I was very
suspicious of the Miles stories.
They were, they were serving
a certain, should I say?
Male purpose in the
fifties and sixties.
There was similar, similar
to sports hero stories.
I was very suspicious
about that kind of thing
because I was getting
crosswinds from musicians
that didn't sound the same.
Yes, Miles could be
at least annoying
and often very nasty and cruel.
But he was also an
extraordinarily generous
and thoughtful person.
And I thought, this is
something worth exploring
to see how you pull
all of it together.
I mean, I already passed the
point where I thought what?
That to be great, you
don't have to be nice.
Nice people-- in fact, most
great people aren't very nice.
Because they're, they're so
committed to what they do.
So one single person,
single purpose
that they devote themselves to.
And everything else
falls apart around them.
So I wasn't surprised by that.
But what I was surprised
by was how much he was thinking
ahead of the other people.
And why he would do that.
And why he would be breaking
the rules constantly.
So this guy who has
all the, the trappings
of a super-macho
star, if you want.
Will nonetheless do things
which no macho person would do
such as play Broadway
show tunes in the fifties.
Whoa, you know?
The only two people
to pull that off were,
were Chet Baker and he.
Chet Baker had a voice
that sounded female.
So you know he crossed
a lot of borders.
So I'm wondering, who else,
who else is going to play
as a super cool tune either
Surrey with a Fringe on Top,
really corny Oklahoma tune?
And even then.
Or maybe Bye-bye Blackbird,
an ancient song which--
so what does he do
with both of them?
He plays them so slow, they
lose their original feel.
>> Larry Applebaum:
He strips away.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, and Bye-Bye
Blackbird he plays [hums]
and drops the "blackbird."
[Hums] something a singer
would never be able to do.
So he's [inaudible].
And then when you look at
some of his early work,
it's just the arrangements
that we use for his,
birth of the cool recordings.
There is a kind of erasure
going on there, too.
He'll take a tune
that's based roughly
around a George Shearing
composition.
A kind of quasi-be-bop player.
And he'll drop a lot
of the harmonics of it.
So there's empty spaces, and
it's floating in between.
I notice that incidentally,
I just remembered
something on erase.
If I can remember
the details of this.
Rauschenberg, the painter, got
the idea that it would be cool
to erase a famous
painter's painting.
Then put his name on
it for erasing it.
So he went to de Kooning and
said you can't erase a painting.
So he settled on a drawing.
Have you got a drawing
I could erase and do it?
De Kooning said,
"This is stupid."
[Laughter] He said, "I know,"
he said, "but I want to do it."
So de Kooning goes
through a lot of stuff.
So he pulls out something.
He says, "Here."
And so he takes it.
By the way, he didn't
completely erase it
or that would sort of spoil it.
You could kind of see it.
But it's mostly gone, and he
wrote his name at the bottom.
End of story.
And he's famous.
Sold for a lot of money.
Well, Elaine de Kooning, de
Kooning, and Willem de Kooning
and Elaine de Kooning,
both writers,
both painters, were
big jazz people.
And Elaine did a charcoal sketch
of Ornette Coleman
which is quite good.
I, I have a copy of it.
And it's signed Elaine
de Kooning.
So I was at-- you can see
it on the web, by the way.
I was at Ornette Coleman's
birthday party, and he passed
out copies of these as sort,
no, it was a Christmas Party.
Christmas presents.
I look at it, and Elaine de
Kooning's name has been erased,
and his name was there.
So I said, "I bet this
is by Elaine de Kooning."
He said, "Yeah, but
it's me, it's not her."
So somehow jazz history
[laughter] walked back
into art history.
Erasure.
>> Larry Applebaum: So
with Miles, are there any,
I mean you, you immersed
yourself in what is out there.
You interviewed all
the right people.
Are there any unanswered
questions
in your mind about Miles?
>> John Szwed: Well, there's
always something unanswered.
I mean, I don't ever claim
to know anyone that well.
I mean, I'm not surprised
by much
that people do unless it's
completely outrageous.
I mean, how do people hold
values that seem contradictory?
How do they operate in that?
How do they, how do they move
between different
behavior levels?
How can they be at different
levels of society and do that
and still maintain
some kind of integrity?
The kind of thing that most of
us find hard to do, I think.
It's people who, who
are as comfortable
with the maintenance
people as they are
with the CEO are rare
unless they're exposed-- .
What's the word I want for that?
A certain kind of character
who, kind of person who says,
"Your mother just died.
Let's go on a vacation."
Or for jazz context, the great
Latin drummer whose name is
slipping away from me.
But Dizzy Gillespie-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: Chano Pozo.
>> John Szwed: Chano Pozo,
when he was shot to death
in a Harlem bar, it said that
someone walked into Birdland
and yelled out, "Chano
Pozo's bee killed."
And somebody at the bar
said, "Never mind that,
how was his last set?"
Well, it's probably untrue,
but you, the spirit of it-- .
>> Larry Applebaum:
It's a good story.
Apocryphal or not.
>> John Szwed: But it gets,
it gets something out.
And maybe that's the
way we should operate.
How was their last set?
>> Larry Applebaum: What did you
think of Miles' autobiography?
First, first of all, do you
think it captured his voice?
>> John Szwed: Everyone
said it did.
To the degree that he
talked too much, yes.
He would have said a lot less
and no matter what it is,
he would have said less.
I can't get across
how that works.
Well, a small case did happen.
Someone who brought their young
child up, ten-year-old kid.
Said, "My son's only ten,
but he plays trumpet.
He loves your music," and so on.
And the kid said, "I
really love your music."
Miles says, "You're
only ten years old.
What do you know?"
That's a cruel thing to say.
But it's true.
>> Larry Applebaum: Speaking
of true, I know that you,
the tapes of the
interviews that formed
that autobiography
are a chomper.
And you have read the
transcripts of those tapes.
How accurate is what is in
the autobiography as opposed
to what is in the transcripts?
>> John Szwed: Well, to
answer that, I'd have to say
that when you move from
interview to anything else other
than quoting one-liners.
You have to create a narrative.
You have to create something
with a beginning, a
middle, and an end.
And in this case,
it's a life story.
And you have natural
beginning, middles, and ends.
And you have to make
those things work.
And the same thing is true
whether you have an interview
or letters or, or whatever.
Overheard conversations.
You're still going to have to
make them fit those things.
To that degree, no
biography is ever accurate.
It's always, it's always going
to create a flow, a flowchart
or a timeline which is not.
Which may be correct
historically,
but that's not the way
it was lived and felt.
If you, if you're not very
careful, and most aren't,
you begin to say
how the person felt.
And the kind of biography
I really hate says,
"He must have felt.
He probably thought."
And most of them say this.
And all you're hearing is some
fool who's, who's conjecturing
to keep the story going.
Well, we all do that
when we're trying
to tell a story to someone.
You know, what happened
yesterday, you,
you tend to throw things in.
I said this to him and
he was saying so-and-so.
Well, that plus the
fact that you look at a,
you look at an interview.
And interviews don't
flow that nicely
and they're not chronological
usually.
So a lot of juggling's
got to go on.
And then to keep
the narrative going,
you can't possibly use
those quotes sequentially.
And what I, I found was that
this was where it was departing
from its-- you have a choice.
Either to leave it out
or make it scattered.
Now i-- I'll come back
to that in just a second.
This, they tried to keep
the narrative going.
This is [inaudible] and
frequently this required leaving
out things, and that's
part of the game, I guess.
And this was changing
the details of it.
And it's readable.
As a result, it got
very good reviews.
The book's still for sale.
Mine's not.
I mean, you know, whatever.
And in fact, this
is what really hurt.
When I got reviewed
in the New York Times.
I got two bad reviews
in one week.
Nobody gets two reviews
in one week to begin with.
That was really weird.
My agent said, "Well, it means
it's really important, right?"
I said, "Yeah, right."
One rather famous person said
my book should be read by people
who are really interested
in Miles.
And Miles' book is full
of inaccuracies and
made-up stories.
But his is much more
fun to read.
Well I grant that.
That's why it was done.
That's why it's-- but
I'm not writing it,
I'm not writing books
for fun, I guess.
>> Larry Applebaum: Why are
you writing these books?
>> John Szwed: In that case,
to correct what was written.
And because I thought,
I thought every writer.
I thought, I know, every writer
who had written about him cut
out the parts of his
music they didn't like.
And I thought that
was unconscionable.
That's like saying
of a business person.
They were you know
dealing in gold,
and then they were
dealing in something else.
You decide I don't
like the gold part.
I'll leave that out.
Sounded dumb.
You know, he should--
I don't want him-- .
It creates a character
that's totally different
than any other one.
Or a person who, who
beat up his partner.
I mean, leave it out and
you've got another story
of another person.
>> Larry Applebaum: Can you
give some examples of things
that are commonly left
out of these biographies?
Not just of the Miles, but
let's say the Billie Holiday.
>> John Szwed: I think the first
thing that's left out I'd love
to be able to do that
I can't do is to talk
about just how boring
life can be.
Even when you're wealthy and
you're a start and so forth.
There's a lot of boredom.
I mean, I sensed a little
of this at a low level
as a traveling musician and.
I mean just think.
Let's leave aside
music for a second.
What if you're really a
star, a super, super figure?
And you've just appeared
at Kennedy Center.
You've had people leaping
to their feet and so on.
And you go back to the hotel.
That's a big jump.
What are you-- watch
CNN or something?
>> Larry Applebaum: Do
your laundry in the sink.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, it's-- .
One way you handle
it is make your life
into a kind of a, I don't know.
I don't think a lot of
people handle it, frankly.
I think it causes
them a lot of grief.
But one is to try to
believe your own propaganda.
Believe the audience and
say, "I'm always that.
I'm always on."
And I think musicians have
a different take on this.
I think, particularly those who
aren't singers because they,
they're like abstract painters.
They're not, they're not
saying this is reality.
They're saying this
is in my head.
It's a feeling.
So I don't have to
live with that feeling.
Although some do.
Miles and Chet Baker were
cool characters in their time.
They walked, talked,
they had minimal speech.
They, they stared at people.
I mean, that's why
they're so quotable
because they so, said so little.
You know this.
In fact, I compared
the two of their,
their, the way they moved.
They were similar players.
And Miles' story, stories
about Miles always ended
with some very funny but
rude or violent comment.
Every story about Chet
Baker ended sadly.
There was nothing
funny about it.
I mean, the funniest
one I know is
when he met Benito
Mussolini's son.
Who was a jazz pianist.
You know who I mean, right?
He said, have I got it right?
"It was a drag what
happened to your dad."
I mean, that wasn't meant
to be funny but [laughter].
>> Larry Applebaum: But
this is what gets quoted
over and over again.
And this is what
I mean about-- .
>> John Szwed: Bob Dylan
is experiencing this
by the way, you know.
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah, it's,
there's this process of sort of,
I don't know if it's
romanticizing suffering
or tragic, or tragically
misunderstood.
Or, or what we think artists are
supposed to represent for us.
But I sense that for the
readers of these biographies,
and I'm assuming, I mean maybe
I should ask you straight up.
Who are you writing for?
Are you writing for
the knowledgeable?
the general audience?
I mean, nobody gets rich
writing jazz biographies.
So why are you doing it?
>> John Szwed: I actually never
thought of it which is a flaw.
You know, you should
always create your audience,
not assume it.
I hope somebody's
there to read it.
I mean, from the
very first words,
you start shaping an audience
and somebody goes, "That's it,
I'm not going to read anymore."
>> Larry Applebaum: Is
that how you approach this?
>> John Szwed: I just, I
just started writing it.
It was not automatic
writing, but it was,
I had no idea of an audience.
And I was just thinking
about Johnny Lydon
has produced several--
Johnny Rotten as he's know,
Sex Pistols and PI and so on.
He's written two,
two autobiographies.
Both of them interesting.
In the most recent one,
he said, "You know,
being Johnny Rotten 24 hours
a day was a tough job."
I knew exactly what
he meant, right?
He was trying to hold
that character in place.
You can't do it.
Actors can't hold
their roles very well.
Or they don't, you
know, they can try
to fake their way through.
But they don't go
through life like that.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Besides, it's a,
it's a contrivance to do that.
Whereas we always celebrate
people being who they are.
>> John Szwed: That's why people
who don't say much have a
better chance of pulling it off.
It becomes like I think I
said somewhere it's like Da--
Daisey in the Great Gatsby.
She spoke so softly
and so little you know,
you were taken [inaudible].
Well, I finally read the
first version of Gatsby.
And she talks a lot more and
is much rougher on her husband.
But it blows the book.
I mean, somewhere.
Oh, it's where the rich,
the rich Anglo-millionaire
is talking
about the lower races
in the United States.
And this is the twenties, right?
He said, "They're going
to take over the world.
They're not like really creators
of the world they're
taking over."
And suddenly, Daisey wakes
up and says, "Kill them all!
Kill them all!"
And he says, "Alright,
don't start with me."
And then later in the
same exchange, she says,
"We're all white
people here, you know."
But that's not a book
that would have sold.
[Laughter] He took
that stuff out.
>> Larry Applebaum: As,
as a writer, biographer,
as a scholar, I'm wondering
how you assess research value.
>> John Szwed: Research value?
>> Larry Applebaum:
Research value.
And by that I mean when you're
going through papers, let's say.
What are the kinds of things
that make your eyes light up?
What's, what's-- where's
the gold in that stuff?
>> John Szwed: Well I think most
of the time, unless you're going
to repeat things
that are well known.
You have to hope that something
is that you haven't seen
or heard and the problem there
becomes the way I open my
Miles book.
I was down in Soho
at a bar in New York.
And I was talking
about this at the bar.
And someone overheard
and said, "Miles?"
And he gives me a
story about Miles.
And it was outrageous,
both its content,
but also it was impossible,
given the circumstances.
So I knew it was made up.
So I said, "Where'd
you hear that a story?"
And he goes, "You
want provenience?"
I mean, he said,
"This, this is--
we're talking about Miles here.
Miles belongs to everybody."
And I said, whoa.
Now this is interesting.
If I'm going to write
down everything
that people tell me he did,
I can have a fat book
of a lot of stories.
But if everyone thinks
this character is theirs,
they're going to be clashing.
They're going to, you
know, stories won't work.
And it was bad enough
as what it was.
So I, I, I was on
guard about this.
And I, I found this
about sexuality.
That people will give
you these stories.
That of a given person, everyone
I've ever written about.
That seem to be impossibly
sustainable.
They can't have that much, I
don't want to say versatility.
It's not about that.
Their range of sexuality
is impossible,
or almost impossible
to maintain.
It would be a full-time
job to do it.
And you'd have to work at it.
Which is not exactly what
we think these things should
be about.
And slowly you begin to find out
that none if it's quite right.
That they've taken something
and pushed it further.
And you know, every now
and then I'd be brought
up short by somebody.
So I get a call once
when I was working
on this Sun Ra book
from Out magazine.
I don't know whether
they still exist or not.
They said, "We're interested
in doing a piece on Sun Ra."
So they started asking some
questions and said, "Ooops,
not out enough for us."
That was the end of that, right?
So they were pulling him
out of the gay realm for me,
editing him out in that way.
Miles, people kept
trying to push him back
in these two, in
these categories.
I mean, they would, I can,
"So and so was there."
It's always third
or fourth stories.
And what are they trying to say?
That the other one is the
fake and this is the real?
They're not saying that
both are real, for sure.
I'm so maybe it's the period
we're in where people want
to see these kind of-- it's
like debunking the
character sexually.
You know? The macho guy
is really the opposite.
Or you know the wimpy
guy is really macho.
It, it's-- i don't
know how that works.
But it's, it's boring to hear.
And the stories aren't
very interesting.
I mean look, most
of life is tedious.
Most of the dialogue is boring.
>> Larry Applebaum: But
nobody wants to read boring
or tedious, much less buy it.
So what they want is
the stuff of heroes.
>> John Szwed: Well, I
mean, I thought that,
that a black kid whose
father was an orthodontist,
who raised prize-winning horses
and bought prize-winning swine
from Winston Churchill who
studied at Julliard and studied
with the first trumpet player
with St. Louis Symphony.
Who was also kind of a
proto-beatnik, a junky,
street person who
had made films.
Who had gotten the
highest award.
Who set fashions and so on.
I thought that was story enough.
And I had to get to
people like his tailor.
But the problem was he
kept shifting styles.
So I went to the Audubon
Men's Shop in, in Cambridge
which is the arch-preppy
shop, still is of all time.
You walk into that shop,
and it's like walking
into a certain zone of history.
Now fortunately for me, the
owner was a Miles freak.
And he saw the humor
of all of this.
He saw the humor of Miles
coming in with certain fabrics
and saying, "I want a
suit made like this."
And they were-- you
know, best [inaudible]
and I don't know, whatever.
You know certain kinds of tweed,
and the next time he sees him,
he's getting Italian suits that
are coming from somewhere else.
And then he's getting
Japanese clothes
that are [inaudible] around him.
Then he's got whatever.
So he saw the humor of this,
changing your life
to fit your fashions.
And when I went to
people like that,
to see how they would take the--
what would your tailor
say about you?
Or I went to his dentist.
That was interesting.
His dentist, nice man, retired.
Said-- he kept changing
the subject.
He, he said, "You
know Mr. Ellington?"
I'd say, "No, I don't.
I know who you mean."
He said, "Very sweet man.
He's been one of my
patients for years."
And I'd say, "Well, please
can we get back to Miles?"
And he's say, "By the way,
do you know"-- you
know some singer.
And I'd say, "No
but you know-- ."
"It's a sweet lady
and wonderful teeth."
I'd say, "Dr, can we
talk about Miles?"
"He wasn't very nice."
[Laughter] I worked
on a molar-- .
So it's that kind
of thing, right?
No story just I worked on this
molar and he wasn't very nice.
>> Larry Applebaum: How
did you approach the Billie
Holiday story?
I mean this is also something
that the narrative's been
picked over often enough.
How did you try?
How were you able to find
something new to say?
>> John Szwed: Well, I, I
was bothered by the fact
that the story of her life
had overwhelmed her music.
And that the very best
of her music was not
being paid attention
to even though it was out there.
It's still out there somewhere.
And I wanted to make a case
for her being a really
important 20th century singer
that set patterns that
you don't maybe recognize.
Since Frank Sinatra and Amy
Winehouse, all kinds of people.
And that was, that was actually
a very easy thing to do.
And I was thinking
not that interesting.
But as I got into it, I
found these other materials.
I found, I found stuff from--
got her co-writer of her,
of her autobiography.
I found the first draft
of her autobiography
which had a lot missing
when it went into print.
I found some people who
that she had had affairs
with that were quite famous and
were missing from these texts
for fear of lawsuits
and other things.
So the, the person who's
self was changing right
in front of me.
Here's a woman who we knew
about an abusive husband
and about gangster boyfriends
and drug dealers
and times in jail.
But we didn't know that she'd
had a long-running affair
with an extremely
rich woman who,
whose mother was the founder
of the Museum of Modern Art
that she's had an
affair with one
of America's leading
women poets.
She had an affair
with Orson Welles.
With Tallulah Bankhead.
Great actress and so I really
got interested in the fact
that she was moving in a much
different level of society
than anything else
had ever told us.
Now one, one reviewer
said I was dropping names.
Yes, I was dropping names.
But I was trying to
rebalance the names
that were already there.
You know, narcs and drug
agents or various sorts.
But now I had two
books going at once.
So I decided well,
I'll do them both
at once and see how it goes.
Had to cut back part of it.
I think, I think I got across
what I wanted to which was
that it's a bad mistake to view
a singer through their songs
and try to read their life.
To read their discography as
a biography, pretty simple.
That there's an acting
phenomena going on here.
You're acting these parts.
You're, you're playing
a part and to think
that the singer is always sad
or always happy or whatever.
That usually they're
sad is a bad mistake.
And I realized that
that's why reviews
of things are constantly
quoting lyrics
as if they were the person.
Is she talking about that?
I mean, is that, you know?
That's, that's pretty
shabby work, I think.
And I wanted to show that
her life was more interesting
than it appeared.
And that she was much
smarter than she appeared
because had been treated as
if she were kind of dopey
and drifting through life.
And that I could curse myself.
I didn't say this clearly.
But I wanted to say that her,
her autobiography
is an indictment
of virtually every
American institution.
From child hood and school
right through to death.
Because each one of
these things fails her.
I should have said that more
strongly and I, I just slipped,
lack of courage or
whatever, I didn't say it.
By and large, I think
I pulled it off.
The Washington Post reviewer
thought it was terrible.
Which is to say I didn't
represent the Billie Holiday-- .
>> Larry Applebaum:
That's what I mean
about people clinging
to their myths.
>> John Szwed: But I mean what,
even at her worst, I mean,
we're talking now physical
worst, mental worst.
She was doing things that
granted were the voice
that most people
don't find great.
She was doing things that great
singers wouldn't dare to do.
I'll just mention a couple.
What singer do you
know would take a song
like Back in Your Own Backyard.
I think that's it.
It's a 1920s Al Gol-- Al
Jolson, you know, dead song.
She sings the song with,
with the same, on the same A,
I think it's A. Same
note 27 times.
Blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
[Inaudible] And even
Gunther Schuller,
great musicologist said
she pushed too hard
on this, you know.
Well, what does she do next?
The next note, the
point where she was
in this song is the
highest not of the song.
She sang it as the lowest note.
Then when she reaches a point
where the lowest note should be,
she sang the highest note.
So those 27 repeated
notes puts you in tension.
Like what?
And then suddenly, it's
going all over the place.
And they're exercises
in vocal artistry.
Always rhythmic and so on.
Or-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: By the way,
do you think that's something?
Those choices she made?
Were those in the moment?
Or is-- ?
>> John Szwed: Oh, absolutely.
Her stuff is different.
>> Larry Applebaum:
An alternative tape would
show a very different/
>> John Szwed: Yeah, I mean
the tricky thing you're talking
about with her is
she does something
that nobody else has done.
And I don't even know
how you'd learn to do it.
She never sings on the beat.
Now most people hear
it as off the beat.
And you'll find right now
[inaudible] wrote the other day.
She always was behind the beat.
Well, if you're always behind
the beat, when the band ends,
you'd still be singing.
So that can't be right.
She's going behind the beat,
then in front of the beat.
And bouncing back and forth.
And that was the trick.
And I had some students
who charted
out both how her voice
worked in terms of the band.
And their beat and
the beat of the music.
And she's never on
either one of them.
Now here's a singer who
was not taught to do this.
I don't know how you teach it.
But naturally had a feel for
rhythm that said don't do that.
And if I you know if you were
to take a young singer now
and say here's how
you can be a success.
Don't ever sing on the beat.
And then by the way throw
in, and by the way pick
as your favorite songs
one about lynching.
One about being a poor child.
And the other about being a-- .
What's the third one?
Can't remember it.
These are all bad
career choices.
She should have been terrible.
She should have been awful.
>> John Szwed: But
nobody follows.
I mean, the point is she
didn't have those rules.
She was constantly breaking
rules in creative ways.
And this I think is what
has always bothered me
about the myth.
Is that it takes you away from
the brilliance of what she did.
And instead dwells
on her suffering.
>> John Szwed: I was pleased
that I, I, I dared to say
that some of her
technique Bob Dylan uses.
And I'll stick with that.
Bob Dylan knows that-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: On the
most recording he made?
>> John Szwed: No, no, no.
Always. And damned if
he hasn't said as much.
He said, "Billie
Holiday and I were,
were had the same
kind of problems.
People [inaudible]
we had bad voices.
And they said we were behind
the beat," and so forth.
But he knew it.
I had, I had, I had
a couple things
down that, rather famous ones.
I hesitate to mention now.
If I get it wrong.
But it was one of the early
rock things that he, he's back
and forth on the beat.
I, I always noticed that.
And I, I don't think he's
doing it on the new things.
Maybe out of a kind of
discretion about it.
He's at a funny place
on that stuff.
But Dylan's very
conscious of where he set.
And then he said, "Don't' forget
that Jon Hammonds signed
me, and so did she."
And then I looked to
Hammond, and Hammond said,
"You think I took a lot of
grief for signing Dylan,
nothing to what I got when
I signed Billie Holiday."
They said, "This
is not a singer."
And that's what they
said about Dylan.
So I thought I was
on safe ground then.
>> Larry Applebaum: When
you found first of all,
how did you find the draft
of her autobiography?
Was it at the published?
>> John Szwed: No, it was in
an archive of Robert O'Meely,
a Professor of English
at Columbia.
And-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: In
his personal collection?
>> John Szwed: Yeah,
and it was onion skin,
the way they used to keep them.
>> Larry Applebaum: How did
he find it, do you know?
>> John Szwed: I've learned
not to ask those questions.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay.
>> John Szwed: I don't, I
don't want to sound strange.
It's just do I need
to know that?
>> Larry Applebaum: I'm curious
about where-- about provenance.
Anyway.
>> John Szwed: I wasn't
criminal, I'm sure.
It's like finding
the, the first attempt
at a Billie Holiday biography by
a woman who killed herself here
in D.C. at a prominent hotel.
No one had bothered to
take it out of the library.
It was just sitting there.
No one thought to take it out.
They didn't look at it.
And I looked at it and said,
you know, 600, 800 pages here.
>> Larry Applebaum: So the
changes between the draft
and what finally gets published.
How much of that is a
professional editor who's
striking things out.
And how much of it was Billie
saying, "No, I don't want
to tell these stories"?
>> John Szwed: Well, first of
all, she had as a co-author,
who was himself a prize-winning
journalist who had done none
of the reviewers then.
It came out in '56, or now,
bother to look him up to find
out that he had, he had written
the first, the first long series
of ar-- well, the first.
First series, but the long
series too of drug addiction
in New York in the early '50s.
He wrote a prize-winning piece
on Puerto Ricans in New York
and their problems with
housing and jobs and so forth.
Back when they were more,
more of a new phenomenon.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Is this William Duffy?
>> John Szwed: Yeah, and he had
also been a political speech
writer for I forget
who it is now.
He had, he had been a writer
for a labor magazines,
for union magazines.
He had this big career, and
he was the, the top writer
of the New York Post
at the time.
They treated him as a hack.
And they always say he
was a hack tabloid writer.
Well, I mean tabloid is
a shape of a newspapers.
That's a cheap thing to say.
This guy had good credentials.
He had, and he knew the music.
He played piano.
And he's done some
gigging and stuff.
And then I found his letters.
Through a partner of his.
And I found that he had taken
on her critics at least,
if not written about
them publicly,
in a rather severe and,
and interesting way.
For example, when-- .
When Strange Fruit
appeared and this was seen
to be a song about lynching.
That set off all kinds of bells.
So southerns didn't
want to hear the song.
If you were objecting to it.
And people were saying
that the FBI contacted her.
Wanted to know if the
Communist Party had urged her
to write the song.
It turns out it was written by
a member of the Communist Party.
That-- they hadn't looked
that up yet I guess.
[Inaudible] Yeah, who's
who adopted the Rosenberg,
the Rosenberg children after
the parents were killed.
>> Larry Applebaum: Oh,
I didn't' know that.
>> John Szwed: But the FBI
hadn't looked that up yet.
So they were coming
from the wrong end.
So I'm trying to think who
he wrote this letter to.
This is her, her co-writer.
He said, he said the FBI
and, and critics have said
that this poor, ignorant black
girl, barefooted in their mind,
isn't able to think for herself.
In fact, several writers said
that she didn't know
anything about lynching.
When it was a common
phenomena at the time.
Everyone knew about it.
And said [inaudible] was this
ignorant, illiterate person.
When in fact, she knew every
word of that personally.
She knew the consequences
of it and so on.
And said she could have easily
have sung faux spirituals
like Marian Anderson,
you know, in Washington.
A famous incident in the
[inaudible] or somewhere.
And passed herself off
as a good Christian girl
who was you know knew her place.
And said she wouldn't
touch songs
with fake singing like that.
Everything she sang was
from personal feelings.
She was a-- I'm slaughtering the
emotion which she put to this.
But he was pointing out
this huge, you know, almost,
almost conspiracy between
journalists and institutions
of justice to present,
to nullify the song.
To treat it as a not
important document.
And a song about
lynching as a pop song?
Whoa? Then or now,
you know, is stunning.
And to perform it in nightclubs
with people with drinks
in their hand and goof food
was not only outrageous,
but it required a whole staging.
Which meant the lights
had to go out.
You had to shift
the whole atmosphere
or the whole place would
be in chaos, right?
>> Larry Applebaum: Little
pin spotlight on her?
>> John Szwed: Yeah.
Well, I mean, I hated the idea
that she was just
called a jazz singer.
Because the early jazz people
didn't call her a jazz singer.
So now she's, she's
being called it
when jazz is not in its heyday.
When it was in its heyday,
she wasn't a jazz singer.
>> Larry Applebaum: So
there was a response
to the book at the time.
Whether it was from her
peers or whether it was
from the general public.
And then it's maybe
two generations later
that people experience
it again with the film
that was made starring Diana
Ross based on the book.
Do you have any thoughts
about that film?
>> John Szwed: Well, I
mean, she was a good singer.
As good of singing as she did.
But it wasn't Billie
Holiday's singing.
But beyond that, and
this is something
that Diana Ross herself
questioned.
That the, the biography was
being scuttled here entirely
to create a new figure.
And Barry what's his name.
>> Larry Applebaum: Gordy.
>> John Szwed: Gordy, yeah
said his famous remark was,
"White people change the
biographies all the time
in the movies.
Why can't we?"
Well, it's hard to
argue with that
because it's what does happen.
They turned it into
a fifties melodrama.
With a, with a housewife
becoming crazy it opens with.
You know, and a straightjacket,
screaming on the floor.
Billie Holiday didn't scream.
[Inaudible] I mean, come on.
But then they introduce this
sympathetic male character who's
more like a father
than her lover.
Who's going to make
things right.
I found it disgusting, but hey.
It won some prizes.
It did well.
I mean, you know.
I said the same thing
about Jelly's Last Jam
which I thought was an atrocity.
It won six Tonys.
Using swing arrangements
instead of--
and not his tunes
because he had trouble
with [inaudible] the author
of the book they were using.
So I had trouble with [laughter]
all those films that attempt
to do history of black music
as if it were done yesterday.
>> Larry Applebaum: Well,
they're not documentary
films, these feature films.
Are there, do you think there
are any well done feature films
about this music?
>> John Szwed: That's
a tough one.
>> Larry Applebaum: I mean,
did you like Round Midnight?
Young Man with a Horn?
>> John Szwed: I
liked things about it.
I didn't think it
was because of that.
I mean, I thought Young Man
with a Horn was a nice picture
of New York at that time
and some other things,
daring writing and.
I thought-- what was
your other example?
Round Midnight?
I thought I had some
nice stuff in it.
I thought some of the
music was ill-chosen
for the acting was brilliant.
I found out that Dexter Gordon
had been re-writing his part
every day.
And I talked to the
director about it at length.
He said he'd come in and
say, "I can't say this."
And so you know, I was
really impressed with that.
But I found the film a downer
in the wrong sense of the word.
Has there ever been a good one?
I'm about to say no.
But hold on.
There's a funny way in
which the Chet Baker story,
which nobody's seen, I guess.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Oh, the recent film?
>> John Szwed: The funny way
in which I found it interesting
in spite of all its flaws.
I think because it was so
understated and on the edge
of boring that they
really had his character.
Whereas the Miles film was
going over the top to turn it
into a Buddy film, action film
in which Miles' character
gets lost entirely.
To that degree, the one
film is much better made.
The other film is, is
cheaply made by necessity
but stayed closer
to the character.
Not that it was great.
Let's see, there must
be something here.
Well what's that film with
Louis Armstrong playing a-- .
>> Larry Applebaum:
A Man Called Adam,
yeah with Sammy Davis Junior.
And Frank Sinatra Junior.
>> John Szwed: Too
Late Blues maybe.
>> Larry Applebaum: Oh, yeah.
>> John Szwed: But
nobody sees those films.
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah, well
they're worth seeking out.
I mean, it's like the music.
You, you have to know what
to look for or to listen for.
And the people who are truly
interested will seek them out.
>> John Szwed: There
were also those TV films
like Johnny Staccato.
Nobody knows that.
>> Larry Applebaum: That's
another [inaudible] isn't it?
>> John Szwed: Yes, which
was Second City used
to mercilessly parody.
This is a, you know
kind of small jazz bar
from the neighborhood.
Private detective
comes in and plays.
Sits in with the band.
Good musicians if I recall.
Really serious musicians
playing.
He'd sit in on piano.
And it's-- a crime would
occur, and he'd go solve it.
And Second City which,
I guess they're--
turned into Saturday
Night Live later.
They have him saying,
"Well I've got
to finish the set
before I go outside."
So people are getting their
throat cut, beaten up.
He'd go out there,
he's always too late.
But there was also
a nother Peter Gunn.
Peter Gunn had a kind
of laconic, you know,
whatever kind of quality to it.
People are being beaten
up, the music is going on.
Yeah, well, finish
the drink and.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Pretty good music in that.
Henry Mancini.
>> John Szwed: It was, it
was-- who was the director?
A big time director leader.
But they had the idea that
something-- [inaudible].
He thought you can make
a bar a world, you know.
What happens in a bar.
The first time I had
ever been in a bar.
I think I was 15 at a place
called Billie [inaudible] I had
that feeling.
It was, it was a little place
that had been a prohibition
place in Philadelphia
in a back alley,
dead end street.
It was perfect.
It was filmed a lot.
And Billie [inaudible] was
a clarinet player and he'd,
between sets would tell you
about Al Capone or whatever.
And how he stiffed,
Al Capone stiffed him.
And the musicians are
crowded in a corner.
And as young as I
was, I mean, I could,
I thought I could live in there.
In fact, I remember
it very clearly.
First, I walked in the door, and
I saw something so impressive.
I've never forgotten it.
The bartender who I thought was
old, but he probably was 40.
Saw two men about
to hit each other.
They were shoving.
He leaped over the bar,
just sprung over, you know,
which is an act of
real strength anyway.
Landed right beside them,
put his around them and said,
"Gentlemen, gentlemen.
Surely we can solve
this in civilized ways.
We're all gentlemen here.
I'll buy a drink
for both of you.
Please sit down, not
next to each other.
But please sit down, son."
He sits them down,
and he walked away,
I saw he had a sawed
off poll cue stuck
in the back of his pants.
And I thought you know, this
is [laughter] I could stay
in this bar.
And then I heard
[inaudible] by you know,
a song that is as
sad as it comes.
You know about what
it's like in those bars.
What your life is like.
By the way, did you
see Lady Gaga sang
that at the a couple, couple-- .
[Inaudible] I don't know
if people know this,
but it's a song about
failed love, alcoholism.
It's drinking your life away.
Living with people
who are drunks.
Sad.
>> Larry Applebaum:
There's also a film.
Do you know this film?
Yeah, it's Forest
Whitaker and Jeff Goldblum
about two jazz musicians
in New York.
Talk about obscure films.
Feature films.
>> John Szwed: Girls who
had all [inaudible] faces.
Distant [inaudible] traces.
That was it.
Sad and distant gray traces.
Well I mean.
What was I thinking
of with that?
Oh, yeah, when it was sung by
Lady Gaga at the Academy Awards,
the ending goes down the scale.
And there I'll live while I rot
with those whose
lives are lonely too.
She takes it up.
It's triumphant.
And I thought, how can
you see this as a triumph?
Perverse.
>> John Szwed: Yeah.
We've been talking a lot
about your past glories.
I want you to catch us up.
And let's talk about
what you're doing now.
What's this book
you're working on?
And why don't you
talk a little bit
about what you'll be
researching while you're here
at the Library this week?
>> John Szwed: Maybe I
can make this same answer
to one, maybe not.
Well, I'm doing a
book on Harry Smith.
And my experience has
been when I say that,
the two responses,
one is Harry who?
And those who know him,
say, "This is a mistake.
Don't do it."
And that was generally
the publisher's view.
The cool people would say,
"Oh, I know this [inaudible].
Take it to the seniors."
Who'd say no, no, no.
This is not a book.
Harry Smith is known
for introducing a very
influential six-LP set back
in '52 that changed the
nature of folk music
in America ever since.
Dylan recorded I think 14 or 15
of the songs from that album.
They were, they were songs
that had been around,
had actually been recorded 20--
, 25 years before but somehow
seemed like they were from Mars.
They were so different,
sound was different.
The quality of voices.
And it sort of gave
license to a new kind
of singer, Dylan, for example.
They didn't have to
sing like other people.
So he's known for that.
And the daring of doing this.
Even though it wasn't an
original thing [inaudible] Lomax
had done it before him.
But before that, he'd been
an experimental filmmaker
in Southern California and
made a number of animated films
which were famous for
either being hand-painted.
Which is nightmarish where you
have to repeat the same frame
and try to get it close
enough to the previous frames.
And then he put interesting
scores to it
like the [inaudible] or Dizzy
Gillespie or, or Zulu dancers,
or something or other.
Or he used cut-outs
from odd sources.
Muscle magazines,
Negro achievement.
I don't know.
He would create these
strange conglomerations
of fantasied, animated figures.
And it moved him-- and he
also did paintings of records,
his recordings and songs.
Where he tried to get a visual
representation of the sound,
not the, the words of it.
He had 15, had had national
acclaim as a student
of Northwest Coast,
Native Americans.
And had already done archeology
and gotten things in museums.
He had salvaged some
totem poles from wreckage.
He had recorded songs and tales.
He was writing-- I'm talking
at 15 years old he writing
grammars, making word lists
of several different
Native American groups.
And so on.
He was, he was invited
to be part of
and may have been inducted
into secret societies
when white adults
couldn't go in.
That would be enough
right there.
But in 1951, he attracted
the interest, the attention
of Hilla von Rebay who
was the basic founder
of the Guggenheim Museum.
It was then called the
Museum of Non-Objective Art.
So he came to New York on
an early Guggenheim grant.
But Harry was also a
junkie and was living
without any means at all.
He had lived part of the time
over a black bar in Filmore,
an all-black neighborhood then.
And he survived getting
free meals
for painting murals
and the like.
He moved, he came to New
York, he said, to meet,
to [inaudible] and monk.
I'm still trying to figure out
how those two things work out.
I'm thinking.
He moved down to East Village.
And off and on for
the rest of his life,
he lived with no income at all.
The money would come
into his hands.
Apparently never
more than say six
to ten thousand dollars a year.
But it was always spent
on some project or other.
And he was sick or drunk or
out of it for much of his life.
But what's interesting
to me is that he drew
around him this enormous
crowd of people.
See if I can rattle some off.
He was once back
for one of his films
which was an animated
version of the Wizard of Oz.
He was backed by
Elizabeth Taylor in the eras
of Avon Products, the era
of A&P, Huntington Hartford.
What was the year?
Big-money people.
Alan Ginsberg underwrote
him for a while.
Had him living there.
The co-inventor of
the helicopter,
Arthur M Young financed
him for a while.
Tennessee Williams
always spoke well of him.
Arthur C Clark asked him
to advise him on 2001.
Lives in the Chelsea free.
It goes on and on.
But the problem here is
there's no coherent life there.
There's a puzzle-- that's
why I did it, frankly.
This is unwritable.
I thought can I do this?
I mean, no one's going to do it.
Can you make something
out of this?
He wound up-- let's see.
He went out to Naropa Institute.
They lived in a little
shack on campus.
Where he would give these
lectures, high on various drugs.
By the way, this guy was so
serious about drugs and art
that he would list in
the notes for his films.
What drugs he was on and at what
point in the film he was using
so he could weigh
them against them.
So he would go to
classes talking
about American Indian stuff, and
he's be very high and cutting in
and out of the lecture.
[Inaudible] Alice Longworth's
Roosevelt's books, right?
You should have, you know.
You never really know
what was happening there.
So the challenge, I thought
was first of all, his,
his books are all in a warehouse
over in Red Hook in New York
because Getty, who has all of
his artworks didn't want them.
And they fill, they
would fill a New York
apartment floor-to-ceiling.
So I said, "I'll
read these books."
It's now become clear
to me, I'm not going
to be able to read those books.
But he did.
He spent all his money
reading this stuff.
>> Larry Applebaum: Did he
make any notes in the books?
>> John Szwed: Yeah, but they're
usually notes to connect things,
like song types, you know.
I mean, he was, he
was into folk song.
He collected, at one point
he was seriously trying
to get every known version
of Shine into the Titanic,
either the song or
the, or the folktale
of [inaudible] the old
Appalachian-type things.
So really different
kind of material.
One is a comic piece about
the guy who doesn't die
on the Titanic, but
he jumps overboard.
No one believes that
it's sinking.
And the one about a
woman who rejects her men
by becomes the coldest
known figure and--
he hates her and so forth.
He's trying to do
that kind of stuff.
And he was collecting
peyote materials,
both eating them
and studying them.
He, he managed to get samples
of every Seminole
women's dress maker.
Which there were 20 some,
patchwork dresses,
very elaborate.
Smithsonian's got them.
In fact, Smithsonian
has films of this stuff.
And his stuff is in the
Louvre, the Smithsonian.
Not here though.
I doubt it.
>> John Szwed: We
have yet to look.
So you're saying
that this is a book
that might well be unwritable.
So how do you write a
book that's unwritable?
>> John Szwed: I don't know.
>> Larry Applebaum: You're
still in the research phase or?
>> John Szwed: Well, I'd
better get out of it first.
Because [inaudible] going to
do a big thing on him in 2019.
If I don't have it done by them,
it'll become a period piece.
I don't know.
There is, there is, is a model
but I couldn't follow it.
The guy, the guy, an English guy
who found a bum who
he befriended.
And he offered to write the
bum's life story which he did.
And then he would give
the chapters to the guy.
And the guy said, "This is
boring and dull and depressing.
No one wants to know
about my life."
And he was going to give the
guy the money from the book,
and now he's depressed too.
Now if you were writing the
book backwards where I turn
out to be a nice middle class
kid with great prospects,
it would make more sense.
So as weird as this sounds,
he wrote the book backwards,
and won a huge cash prize
and it sold very well.
His second book, he discovered
that his landlord who lived
in the basement was a
world-famous mathematician.
Who have made some bad
mistake on one of his projects.
Lost his job at Cambridge
University.
And was living in the basement
on the rice and something else.
And seemed to be half a lunatic.
And he wrote a book
about this guy's life.
And it's filled with drawings
of advanced mathematics
and so forth.
His third book, he
found a huge pile
of manuscript in a dumpster.
And he thought at first it
was by different people.
It was 40,000 pages
of hand-written stuff.
It was one woman's diary.
So he decided he would
write a book on that diary.
And found out she
was still alive.
And off he goes.
Now these are really
interesting books
because they're critiques
of biography.
They tell you there's
something wrong
with biography [inaudible].
And he incorporates
their criticisms.
So both, all three of these
people said, "This is crap."
And he would say,
"Why is it crap?"
Didn't really incorporate
the-- well, I don't know.
I don't think I can do that but.
>> Larry Applebaum: Something
tells me you like a challenge.
>> John Szwed: Yeah, I guess.
>> Larry Applebaum: To
write the unwritable.
>> John Szwed: Is there
anything unwritable?
>> Larry Applebaum:
I don't know.
>> John Szwed: Anything that's
notable should be writable,
right?
>> Larry Applebaum: Yeah.
Sounds, sounds about right.
>> John Szwed: Look,
Sun Ra was unwritable.
>> Larry Applebaum: True.
Well, I don't know.
>> John Szwed: But I'm
very proud of that book.
I'm very proud of that book
because I followed the logic
of what he was reading.
And that took him back into--
he read, who else read the books
that Frankenstein's
monster read?
That became his reading
list, right?
And they're really
important books, by the way.
>> Larry Applebaum:
Did Frankenstein's monster
read Madame Blavatsky?
>> John Szwed: No,
it was too soon.
>> Larry Applebaum: Oh, okay.
>> John Szwed: But he, he
read more important book,
Count Augustine Volney's
The Ruins of Empire which is
like a sci-fi story
of being taken
to see the ruins
of civilizations.
And so forth.
So that is the one where
Africa is the beginning
of civilization, by the way.
So I started reading these
things and wondering, was,
was this character crazy
because he was talking
about things that
sounded insane.
Then I began to find that
they were written about
and these were not--
you know for example.
He was talking about at
one point white people
who pass themselves
off as being Egyptians.
And turning Egypt into a
European country rather
than a, an African country.
Which is quite true.
So I started reading that,
and I found out that the
English upper class at one point
in the 19th century, there
was a movement among them
to declare themselves as
the original Egyptians.
And that to treat
Egyptians as fakes
or as you know savages
of some sort.
But before that had
been a group who thought
of themself as the
original Jews.
now I find it really fascinating
that upper class
people had moved
from being the original Jews
to being the original Egyptians
because in which case they
would to have had to-- .
Ina way I guess they did
drive their ancestors
out of Egypt in the process.
But I thought this
was really strange.
And then they were called,
it was the Identity movement.
Does that ring any bells?
It's [inaudible] on
the news right now.
[inaudible] has some
identity articles.
The Christina Identity movement
included what is his name?
Timothy McVeigh and the
guy, Rudolph something?
The Atlanta bomber?
They were both Christian
Identity people.
Well, these people are the
heirs of that previous group
who think they're the
original something or other.
So I'm pretty proud of this.
You know I can just see
Sun Ra is reading this.
He's reading what he's reading.
He's saying, "Look at
these crazy white people.
They're turning themselves
[laughter].
They're turning themselves into
Jews, Egyptians, and ballers."
[Laughter]
>> Larry Applebaum: It's clear
that you know quite a bit
about a lot of things.
And that shows up
in your writing.
But let me ask this
last question for now.
And, and we'll take
note of the fact
that this is just the first
part of our interview.
You're going to be back
in the fall for part two
of your residency here.
So let me end this
part by asking
since you know quite a bit and
you've used, you draw from a lot
in your writing, in your books.
Are you able to just listen
to music without context?
Just for the joy of it?
>> John Szwed: Yeah, always.
>> Larry Applebaum: And give
me some examples of what kind
of music just brings you
joy, without any backstory.
>> John Szwed: Well,
what context would there
be for Sun Ra music?
I mean-- ?
>> Larry Applebaum: Well, you
know a lot about Sun Ra now.
You know how it all
fits together.
>> John Szwed: I don't-- .
>> Larry Applebaum: But
okay, let's take Sun Ra.
>> John Szwed: But
it's an anti-style.
>> Larry Applebaum: Okay,
so what is it you
like about Sun Ra?
>> John Szwed: Well, I mean, I
like the fact that I was born
in the same town as he was
and was living there
at the same time.
And was then found out I was
living only a few blocks away
from him many years later.
And I thought this is like you
know synchronicity at its best.
And I can, I used to run
into him in various places.
And every time I did, there
was something weirder coming
out of it.
I mean, imagine a guy getting
out of a stretch limo wearing
a gold lame robe and a kind
of space hat, eating a hoagie.
Or going to see him
at Swarthmore College.
A place that was
really an out school
where students really thought
they were the Avant-something.
And they freaked out
when they saw this stuff.
There was just too
much for them.
They ran out.
But what happened
there was out the,
they were selling
records outside.
And they were all blank
with a name on them.
But you couldn't
tell what they were.
And I said to the
guy selling them,
"What kind of music is this?"
He said, "Well, this
is outer space music,
and this is cocktail music."
I said, "Alright, I'll
take one of each."
I come home, it's true.
One was like Tea for Two.
And so and so.
And this was synthesizers going,
flying through the
roof and what have you.
I don't, I don't see a
context for this except
that it's the context
of no context.
It's I mean I made, I made
a context in the book.
But it's, it's, it's crazy.
It leaps across Southern
Baptist belief in this and that.
Southern California
athletic Christianity.
Space abduction myths.
You know I, I just pulled
out all the stops for it.
But I never think of
the music that way.
I mean, I, I, I -- let me see.
Do I ever think of context?
Country music, yeah.
Maybe. But not -- jazz?
Look, it, to me it's
like abstract painting.
You know, if you're going
to go look for something,
you could say, "Oh,
that's really a river."
Or isn't that, you know,
isn't there a person standing
behind that or something?
But that's not what
it was intended to be.
And it's supposed
to be about well,
if I understand abstract
expressionism.
It's supposed to be about
feeling and improvisations.
Supposed to be free expression
of feelings and emotions.
Maybe even spiritual and
surrealistic in some ways.
And so I hear the
music that was too.
It's operating at another level.
And it, I do understand
why drugs work with music.
I mean, I do understand
you know.
Before it damages
you, it does take you
to someplace that's like that.
>> Larry Applebaum: I can
say for myself I love walking
through an art gallery
or museum.
But there's nothing like
walking through this museum
than with an artist who has
a different way to see things
that I might not notice.
>> John Szwed: That's true.
>> Larry Applebaum: And this
is why I love to sit down
and talk to you about music.
Because you notice some things
that I might not
otherwise notice.
>> John Szwed: But
[inaudible] your context.
>> Larry Applebaum: Well, okay.
>> John Szwed: Maybe you're
fine tuning or something?
>> Larry Applebaum:
Yeah, just as a-- .
>> John Szwed: This is
what happens if you walk
through a museum
with the wrong person
because with [inaudible]
Broadway Boogie Woogie.
Well, we know something
about this guy.
They've recreated his
studio from pictures.
And there were piles of
Boogie-woogie records.
And he was playing
them all the time.
He was dancing while
he was painting.
And he intended this to sound,
look like those things sounded
like which is, you
know, colors moving
in cross patterns and so forth.
End of story.
I mean, that's it.
He wrote essays on this.
He talked about the
disappearance of perspective.
Flattening out.
We're working on a simple plane.
Color is not interacting
with color.
Volume is moving
in different ways.
All written out.
So I go to the Museum of
Modern Art to see the show.
They've got the records
piled up there,
and who's the commentator
but Marcellus.
And when Marcellus
looks, this is over,
you know, through earbuds.
It's looking at Broadway
Boogie Woogie and he says,
"You see the black
line around it?"
Which is the frame.
He says, "That's
the powerful force
of Louis Armstrong's trumpet."
Now it turns out that
Mondrian didn't give a damn
about Louis Armstrong.
But you know?
[Laughter]
>> Larry Applebaum: Nice story!
>> John Szwed: I think he
said Boogie-woogie is not
in the [inaudible].
I mean, it's too close
to rock and roll, right?
>> Larry Applebaum:
Lot of nice stories.
We're going to continue this
next time, and I'm going
to look forward to it.
>> John Szwed: Thank you.